[Music]
am I most thankful for my family I'm
thankful for my wife for my daughter my
health is very important my family you
know couldn't be any better it's gonna
be a great holiday for everyone because
we're gonna see a lot of good changes in
America I think we're gonna get a lot of
great jobs back especially here in
Lucerne County we need more factories we
need more jobs we need this to go back
to normal what are you most hopeful for
under a trump presidency a better future
for my grandchildren helpless senior
citizens that a little bit more with
some more of our Social Security money
adjustments have to be made to the ACA
whether it's repealed or whatever
changes have to be made they're out here
every day people complain about it I'm
just looking forward to America being
great again and hopefully more jobs will
open up for people that need jobs and
don't have them
[Music]